and I'm sorry for that.
Sometimes as men, we get to take the easy way out.
And so my journey as a trans person is about reimagining masculinity.
About creating a manhood that isn't measured
by the power it wields, by the entitlements afforded to it,
or any simulacrum of control that it can muster,
but works in tandem with femininity,
and is guided by my spirit.
KKM: Y'all ...
(Applause)
And this has created the space for my femininity to flourish
in a way I had never experienced before.
He never is threatened by my sexuality,
he never polices what I wear or how I act.
I cook but he does way more of the cleaning than I do.
And when we're rushing to get out of the house
and we have so much to handle,
he handles everything,
so I have time to do my hair and makeup.
(Laughter)
He understands that this is my armor,
and he never treats femininity as though it is frivolous or superficial,
and this, and him --
he grows my experience of gender every single day.
TM: I love to watch her get dressed in the morning.
Watching her in the closet,
looking for something comfortable and colorful, and tight,
and safe --
(Laughter)
But it's challenging to watch her negotiate her decisions
looking for something that's going to get the least amount of attention,
but at the same time be an expression of the vibrant and sexy woman she is.
And all I want to do is celebrate her for her beauty,
and the things that make her beautiful and special and free,
from her long acrylic nails,
to her uncompromising black feminism.
(Applause)
KKM: I love you. TM: I love you.
(Laughter)
KKM: There are so many queer and trans people
who have come before us,
whose stories we will never get to hear.
We constantly experience this retelling of history
where we are conspicuously left out.
And it's really hard to not see ourselves there.
And so living out loud for us is about that representation.
It's about having possibility models,
and having hope that love is part of our inheritance in this world, too.
TM: The possibility that we are practicing
is about reinventing time, love and institutions.
We are creating a future of multiplicity.
We are expanding the spectrum of gender and sexuality,
imagining ourselves into existence,
imagining a world where gender is self-determined and not imposed,
and where who we are is a kaleidoscope of possibility
without the narrow-minded limitations masquerading as science or justice.
(Applause)
KKM: And I can't lie:
it is really, really hard.
It is hard to stand in the face of bigotry
with an open heart and a smile on my face.
It is really hard to face the injustice that exists in the world,
while still believing in the ability of people to really change.
That takes an enormous amount of faith and dedication.
And beyond that,
marriage is hard work.
(Laughter)
Piles of dirty socks on the floor,
more boring sports shows than I ever thought possible --
(Laughter)
And fights that bring me to tears
when it feels like we're not speaking the same language.
But there is not a day that goes by
where I am not so grateful to be married to this man;
where I'm not so grateful for the possibility of changing minds,
and rewarding conversations,
and creating a world where love belongs to us all.
I think about our acronym:
LGBTQ2SIA.
A seemingly endless evolution of self and a community,
but also this really deep desire not to leave anyone behind.
We've learned how to love each other,
and we've committed to loving each other throughout changes to gender
and changes in spirit.
And we learned this love in our chat rooms,
in our clubs, in our bars and in our community centers.
We've learned how to love each other for the long haul.
TM & KKM: Thank you.
(Applause)